what's up you filthy [ __ ] animals man
it is hot out here
guess what I'm going on a road trip
today back to my hometown Sacramento
because we are gonna do a very very
special video today I will learn how to
make [ __ ] we're going to learn how to
make coffee at temple which is the
provider from Sacramento that we use at
the matcha joint sit we're doing a road
trip family road trip that's my older
brother right over there if you see him
right over there look at them but on the
way to Sacramento Vince told us about
this dope ass boo-boo Cydia and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna charge up
the Tesla in the meantime and then get
that damn delicious food look at the
ride baby still got it solid whoa so in
order to get your if you're gonna charge
your Tesla across the street you
actually have to cross this way it is a
bunch of cars coming off the freeway so
be careful this purpose area where you
can also get your air brakes axle
spindle and engine checked at the same
time always go to a place where they
touch greasy dirty parts and make your
food it adds the name
I want to talk about the spoon with some
enthusiasm but it literally feels like
Santa's blowing hot ass at me right now
well I can't do this regulars here this
dude is heating order anything we just
walked away he said she went here we
have this very popular Salvadorian
Salvadorian and typically you'll see it
on Buddha's as well what the [ __ ] do
they have kimchi what is this
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] okay you know what
we're not doing this we're not doing it
that's one I want to get that string
imported
salty the melty okay so
I love this like pickled vegetable like
she said you need that [ __ ] to break up
that back this is fatty as home this
fall so this red sauce man - salsa Bay
[Music]
it's a little squash on the inside all
the little bits and pieces and I'm gonna
take some addition and I'm gonna put
that your side could and I'm gonna take
this right here cousin I'm up do you
want a desk lesson right there here if
you guys haven't met them before this is
the heart of sip including the employees
but these guys are the genius behind sip
I'm just the clown introduce yourselves
I'm Dan I'm
I'm Anna I'm Jeremy
I'm Jeremy and we are right that [ __ ]
was still off but um we have finally
arrived I only drove 300 miles to come
here to this great place Hey
oh [ __ ] did you know the camera guy
Vince and also ugly Lynn got married at
this very very spot I was a crewman here
we're at temple coffee because we are
here to learn about the coffee beans
that we use at sip so I drove all the
way from Los Angeles California because
it's all about the [ __ ] tale
and even though we are a macho centric
business because we do serve coffee we
want to make sure that no matter what we
do or whatever part that we put out we
know exactly what's happening with it
how to serve the best [ __ ] out there and
I'm not just saying that because I
actually really do love coffee but I
don't know too much about coffee so
that's why we're here man we had to
learn and lo and behold look at that
behind us coffee so my name is Mark and
really what we went over today was
consistency the importance of consistent
preparation to control the quality of
our espresso we talked about grinding
and settling in our coffee well the
distribution of our coffee how to
properly town and how to adjust the
grind setting of our espresso to control
how it tastes and how much coffee week
though what he said words when you look
at this couple espressos I'm not have
got contrast I and then I guess like
that's all I ever had this is brother
would you like to fight
[ __ ] what have I learned about David
I've learned that David doesn't like to
study people are talking about things I
have no idea what they're saying I'm
just not even a only that what's going
on it's amazing back to my cheat sheet
that cites mobilities what I learned
that David doesn't like to attention it
was too much for him I know what's up
yeah I already said it no I want to hear
it is 25 to 30 milliliter beverage did
you go quiz me on quiz perhaps tell you
something else
watch this wasn't espresso I asked you
first
what's an espresso Anna
[Music]
nice fries try to pull a David so you
forgot to write on your wrist an
espresso I don't understand how he's
getting worse these people like to be
hurting through their words not Korean
people remember the whole Korean changes
if you don't do that on the first try
it's pretty good I feel like can you do
okay I'm so strong it'll be like just
okay no it'll just be like it's like a
little piece of paper like an Oreo yes I
gotta get it off this side like this
right look at that angle real quick
right now I'm saying
oh damn it went this way now I know what
it feels like
Oh a fella tubes coming some pitches
the partners are here they're right
behind me the coffee bureau of America
oh she represents the bureau the coffee
bureau I can't I can't dispute the
information I know nothing
I'm getting flashbacks I think just me
being around strap sir I'm give a lizard
to a person who's eating fish sometimes
a lake yeah you know how the saying goes
you let a grass grow sometimes but then
when the water hits it is a flower she
goes I give away the cup I like you also
forgot to time it out to June's my
favorite
[Music]